hey guys we're at the Wynn Hotel in Las
Vegas for the Democrat debate the
Republicans have done two of these this
is the first Democrat one so I'm going
to take you into the spin room right now
we're going to see what's going on in
the spin room so this is where all the
media organizations have all their
people on site so all the all the guys
you know from cable news and from
network news are all in here and
everybody gets different different sized
booths depending on how much they want
to pay Fox News is over here now CNN of
course is one of the sponsors for this
one so they've got the big spot in the
middle and that's where they'll be
broadcasting from after the debate
facebook also is one of the sponsors of
the debate so they've got a little
something over here and actually we're
going to be doing some live video on
facebook so you can follow along at
facebook.com/ / dave rubin that's me
seelix CNN there you go CNN right up
there and basically everybody is in here
and this is where this is where all the
campaign managers and the candidates
themselves will come after and then it's
basically like a free melee to to figure
out who you can talk to and we're going
to walk a little bit
around the room Facebook over here
anyway this this one's gonna be really
cool because this is the first
democratic run so this is the first time
that Bernie and Hillary are going to get
to get to talk to each other in front of
people at leisure and what else is going
on you know you got the other tree that
nobody cares about so I'm not even gonna
mention but let's keep going let's show
you got facebook over here and you know
all the usual cast of characters
everybody's everybody's around so yeah
we are going to be on snapchat Rubin
report twitter com / Rubin report MSNBC
is right over here so yeah check us out
play along with us let us know questions
we're going to be doing the periscope
train all of that let us know and let's
see what happens
you